that's Justin Theroux this is mila kunis
what are we doing Justin we're doing the
wired auto-completed
[Music]
so is Mila Kunis and Justin Timberlake
friends yes next question thank you
yes of course is Mila Kunis laughing OH
oh why would anyone ask the Internet if
you're laughing like at the moment that
you're actually doing it okay is Mila
Kunis more attention a gamer um I used
to be and then I had kids so not anymore
never invited me on the Xbox did you
used to do halo I didn't halo where we
do the thing where we'd set up like for
television today with friends we'd say
anything but we all have our own TV
monitor that's the way then everybody
playing Halo yeah is Mila Kunis this
looks like a long one big video game
voice acting I know um I know I did a
video game voice and I don't want to say
what it was because I don't remember but
it was a popular just get it wrong and
try is Mila Kunis fluent in Russian yes
Justin Theroux I am how do you say I
love you in Russia how do you say if I
had known it would have been raining I
would have reminded myself to have
thought to have brought an umbrella here
we go does Justin throw play xbox with
Will Arnett yes I do we play call of
duty you haven't played in a while yeah
but we do play called the whole clan
that goes out there we get online I did
do a call that bonus round I did do a
voice for Call of Duty you didn't know
then I do number that cool does Justin
throw a play guitar not at all give me
any musical play I am an actress am I
technically my body as much with my
siblings yes I have five there's six of
us all together so I had many siblings
says Justin throw oh wait I got one one
speaks French no can you pretend
what does Jesse throat have a dog hmm
does Justin throw a hug oh yeah this was
not planned
look at this this animal is maybe the
laziest that's mom right now she hasn't
moved that's right she's not moved
she's ferocious okay he's gotta be named
by teamuk bites bites a lot and then we
ended up naming her coma she's asleep
does Emily play Meg yes Family Guy
we've been on the air for a couple of
years you should check us out and
sometimes were funny questionable
sometimes it's controversial does Mila
Kunis have a twin why would they asked
that I not that I know of I don't think
that's the one yeah I wish I did okay it
does Mila Kunis have a foot tattoo no
but I have a mole and maybe that's what
people think it is we'll see it in
movies yeah does Mila Kunis Japanese I
think I'm us oh my god little-known fact
fluent are you really a together booth
oh yes I can save you wanna buy a snow
cone can go to get got this guy yeah
that's good I would I use to be able to
I probably could still tell you where
the catering is and where the craft
services and tell you what you can get
cuz I have to say in the movie oh my
gosh yeah does Mila Kunis use eyeliner
however Justin would you like to answer
that question not a stitch yeah I make
you just have to its natural guys oh my
god a stitch I'm right next to you yeah
you can't even see it's just this is
what I wake up looking like yeah what
does Justin throat eat food I mean
technically it's food yeah for the most
part yeah you don't eat humans no no no
sometimes grass yeah sometimes grass
occasions which is ii mean i guess a fit
yeah what does justin theroux do i don't
know
I gotta go what is Justin Theroux dude
today what do i do my stuff living like
living what is just in toasters I'm it's
the best one leo
nothing really different thing August
10th August 14 oh my God we're doing try
to put this party what is just since the
rose height I haven't been measured in a
while and I'm still growing
I think I'm it's like six seven or eight
freakishly tall I'm like the people look
at me and I'm five ten what did Justin
Theroux right Oh many things Justin
Justin Theroux right I've worked on one
I meant to tropic thunder musical where
they once did you write the music for
the musical hello is that it was a
jukebox musical Rock of Ages and I wrote
I've heard Rock of Ages little-known
musical you know starting a little-known
after Tom Cruise yeah he's potential
whenever that's you
here we go so what did mila kunis
neighbor's son do me treat poor
woodcutter what is Mila Kunis my color
dark green yeah they're like a dark
green hazel yeah yeah could be Brown
sometimes used to makes you different
colors everything that was eye surgery
one was blue or on the screen at
cataracts thank what yeah what was Mila
Kunis's age that 70 show interesting
grammar I started when I was 14
whoa that's young that's technically
almost done it's not a child actor it's
a tween it why certain acting I was nine
yeah what was your first job um first
I'll ask Google later the first like
show that I did was days in our lives
mm-hmm and then um and they had a bunch
of commercials so I did like Boeing
commercials and my new what can Mila
Kunis sing la-la-la-la Tinicum it's safe
Nicola yeah spec
[Music]
that was fantastic
are you ready yep is Justin throw we're
late it's Henry do you know because this
is spelled 400 and mine has an X on the
end
a simple spellcheck would have cleared
all that up before clearly not the same
it's just in Thoreau who are your
tattoos real yes all my tattoos are real
how many tattoos do you have Justin well
be weird if I put on tattoos in life
just to go out with fake tattoos I have
a bunch I have like you can't even count
you have that many it's like a lot of
little ones that I'd probably forget if
I started counting on the deals more
than time for you yeah look here's
Justin throw a dad what I had dad I
don't know maybe it might be a bunch of
never know
it's Justin throw and ben stiller friend
yes we are friends and we've been
friends for a very long time where is
Justin Theroux
family from we're from all over the
place a little bit of Italy a little bit
of France a little bit of Montreal
currently we're from everywhere in the
United States were right across the
country first of all the grammar is
horrible for a lot of those questions
like what is Mila cause it's ' what is
Mila Kunis's eye color like possession
of yes exactly yeah
I call it district and I'm born yeah and
I know that there isn't it then clearly
this is her second language it really is
and if you're on the Internet
be nice to each other to each other and
don't Google yourself because that will
make you want to blow your hat
off yeah